emmanuel macron à à la manoeuvre dans la
crise entre la russie et l'ukraine le
président en exercice de l'union
européenne va se rendre à moscou demain
puis à kiev mardi il s'agit de dénouer
la crise le chef de l'état français a
choisi la voie du dialogue il l'a fait
savoir par téléphone au premier ministre
britannique au patron de l'otan les
tractations diplomatiques se poursuivent
elles et précision avec notre
correspondante dans la capitale russe
vera goffman
l'ukraine a continué de dominer
l'actualité internationale cette semaine
le chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov s'est entretenu avec son
homologue américain dennis blair kane le
1er février puis s'en sont suivies les
conversations de vladimir poutine avec
boris johnson et emmanuel macron si
boris johnson et vladimir poutine se
sont mis d'accord sur le fait que l'
escalade en ukraine ne servait personnes
le premier ministre britannique a averti
le président russe qu'une invasion
serait une erreur tragique de calcul la
lumière poutine a quant à lui regretté
que le temps ne soit pas disposé à
répondre aux préoccupations de moscou et
a attiré l'attention de son collègue
britannique sur des violations par kiev
des accords de miesque écouter un
échange de vues assez détaillée a eu
lieu dans le contexte de la crise
ukrainienne et sur les garanties
juridiquement contraignante demandé par
la fédération de russie le président
poutine a exprimé des positions de
principe sur ce sujet une attention
particulière a été accordée aux
sabotages continuent d accord de minsk
par l'ukraine il a été révélé que l'otan
n'était pas prête à répondre de manière
adéquate aux préoccupations raisonnable
de moscou et se cachent derrière la
prétendue politique de portes ouvertes
de l'alliance qui contredit le principe
fondamental de l'indivisibilité de la
sécurité puis jeudi dernier elle a dit
merkel s'est entretenue avec emmanuel
macron pour la troisième fois en une
semaine selon le communiqué du kremlin
un dialogue concret portant sur la
situation en ukraine et les questions
liées à l'initiative russe sur les
garanties de sécurité mutuelle s'est
poursuivie écouter les dirigeants ont
échangé des évaluations de l'état actuel
des affaires y compris au vu des récents
contacts avec plusieurs partenaires
internationaux et dans le contexte de la
présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne vladimir poutine a de
nouveau attiré l'attention sur les
déclarations et actions provocatrices
des autorités de kiev qui vont à
l'encontre des accords de minsk les
tensions russo occidentales sont montées
d'un cran après les allégations
infondées des états unis sur la
préparation par la russie de fausses
vidéos qui justifierait une offensive en
ukraine le porte parole du kremlin
dmitri peskov a appelé à ne pas croire
le département d'état américain sur
parole sergueï lavrov quand les fientes
pour sa part les accusations américaines
de délire écoutez
j'ai lu j'ai regardé sur internet des
déclarations du département d'état selon
lesquelles la russie préparait une
fausse vidéo montrant une attaque de
foot et rue craignent un contre le
dombass
nos ce genre d'histoire sont de plus en
plus nombreuses chaque jour et sont un
délire évident pour n'importe quel
politologue ayant de l'expérience parce
que
le marathon diplomatique se poursuivra
selon dit avec la visite des manuels
macro à moscou pour des négociations
directes avec la dîmière poutine puis ce
sera l'heure de la visite de la chef de
la diplomatie britannique
les strauss le 10 février pour des
pourparlers l'extérieur lavrov enfin le
chancelier allemand olaf scholz a lui
aussi prévu de se rendre à moscou pour y
rencontrer le président russe ce sera le
15 février